we came up with something called the
Blackout Tour which essentially was a DJ
playing EDM music this is at the infancy
of EDM and it exploded like to the point
we had I bought all our own production
you could go to an EDM show it looked
like ours we had a full crew doing it I
thought and were you into it were you
like doing the pills and everywhere you
like partying no we had I I would we we
did three shows a week throughout the
country like we had a whole crew driving
around setting up the lights renting
venues
um I thought I thought I was gonna
become so rich that I'd be like Bezos
and retire we were clearing like 250
Grand to show it was nuts and we weren't
paying for talent so we're charging 50
bucks a ticket selling out literally and
it was just like an EDM party show yes
so This Crew so you guys were just in
Boston and this crew is now traveling
doing shows for you correct like have
you ever heard there's a festival like
bamboozle it's a big Festival in New
Jersey so the Bonnaroo bamboozle was
like like one of those type things yeah
and we were on a call with Live Nation
uh I'll never forget this call like we
want you to close the last music they
had was Bon Jovi they're like we want
you to come on after Bon Jovi and close
it like we'll pay you 250 Grand just to
show up and before we could say anything
like we know it's not a lot of money
it's cheap
um but you'll introduce your music to so
many new people and I was like wait wait
we don't have music what are you talking
about there's no one like what do you
mean you have no music the only thing
they saw was our ticket sales in their
system whenever we put tickets they were
gone in 10 seconds wow so we like did
that turned into a foam thing but but
that was because of the Barstool name
again so you're still like we're just
selling EDM yeah dude because where I'm
from if somebody showed up with damn two
laser lights and a flood beam
dude people would pay fifty dollars nuts
for it they went and it was fun like we
had outside of it like we had Avicii
like playing our thing for like no money
it was before the DJ thing took off okay
so so you did actually have talent
coming to the what yeah we rotate but we
won't pay a lot like we did we paid
maybe two grand for Avicii but it just
they it was before the DJ boom right
then the DJ boom started happening and a
couple things happened we had our name
and we're always sort of controversial
but if somebody OD'd at EDM Vegas yeah
we would be mentioned it'd be like
barcel uh blackout tore part of this and
people would be calling me Insurance
went through the roof
um and news crews were following like
our production around just looking for
controversy so the whole thing as quick
as it came it disappeared so because of
insurance really Insurance EDM it went
from there'd be one EDM show at a
college a month so there were three a
week and we were playing avici's music
and Avicii was going to be there
tomorrow so a whole host of factors and
I was investing this is the gambling
part every cent I made I'm like let's
get the next biggest laser let's get
this let's get that so we put it all
back in at the end of the day we're
probably not even like we we didn't make
money we didn't lose money
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one